Most countries have a central bank, the puppet
master of the economy, the bank of all banks
for that country. The central bank, which we
call the Fed here in the U.S., is run by the
government. So their job is to set the rules or
policies that all the other banks have to follow.
And the central bank isn’t motivated by profit,
but rather their job is to babysit the economy,
to keep it growing, to make sure people have jobs,
to make sure that prices don't fluctuate too much,
so that we can keep growing nicely. No slowdown,
no recession. That is what the Fed is there for.
They pull strings in the economy to get
us to spend our money in a certain way,
which in turn affects how much businesses raise
or drop their prices. And guess what? It totally
works. One of the strings that they have to pull
in the economy is called the interest rate. Want
to borrow money to buy a car or a house or expand
your business? You're going to be way more likely
to do that if you only have to pay 2% interest on
that loan as opposed to like 6%. Lower interest
rates equal people and businesses want to borrow
and spend money. We're like freakin' puppets.